好最近盤面上不只是
总经环境的问题
在产业面上面
也经不起一点点的风吹草动
但是我们之前的经验也是这样啊
后面事情过了
股价涨回原点甚至还创高
所以是不是该把握机会呢
这边来请教小明同学了
今天一开始看到建策跌停板
就想又怎么了
就市场上就说了
三片要降归
降归成几片我是不清楚
等一下你会包我们讲
但今天建策是没有所住的
可见同样的事情再来一次
大家不會那麼樣的驚慌了
但散熱今天有點被影響
另外台積電的擴產也在持續啊
風測其實
8月你收已經很好了
現在看起來第四季會更好
因為我們盤中啊
我說真的台股真的不缺利空
我覺得莫名其妙
我們在行情開始震盪的時候
那種利空的鬼故事就會跑出來
當然我個人還是會特別去關注一下
籌碼的變化
以目前來講啦
外資的這個空單幾萬口
我覺得
明天要結算
那大家其實說真的也不太在意
因為大家也都知道
外資現在這裡有很多的
都是那種避險性的空單
所以你不太能夠期待說
外資的空單全部回補
然後甚至變成再做多
那反而是在散戶的圍台
這個才是讓我最擔心的
原本我們在上禮拜
上上禮拜的時候
一度看到圍台翻空
哇太好了
那也確實啦
後面這邊伴隨著是股價呢
一度要去挑戰歷史高
可是在現階段
圍台包含在今天
跌了三四百點
但是呢
現在三大法人賣了將近800億
結果圍台散戶在這邊還加
這邊多單 加了4000多口
這個是讓我有點擔心啦
所以我們對於明天的結算
我個人是認為
它不要大跌應該就好了
那一方面也是因為現在沒有量能
再加上FOMC利率決策會議在即
市場的氛圍會比較偏向觀望
搭配到現在目前的籌碼
其實我們就算好啦
它不會有什麼太大的波動
我們也不能期待說它會大漲
至少籌碼現在的這個狀況
老實講比較偏空一點
可是也不需要擔心
原因是因為既然我們在結算前
成交量能就先萎縮
而且市場的情緒觀望
代表我們這兩天
正在逐步的消化利空
那你消化掉的利空
後面再有什麼利空
它的衝擊就不會這麼大
那我們來聊一下
關於今天盤通的鬼故事
看到的時候
我是覺得想說
哈哈又來了
怎麼似曾相似
對啊
為什麼是同樣的故事
然後打到跌停板
那我先告訴大家
這一次的傳言好了
第一個是關於Rubin Ultra
它的HBM41
從12層改成8層
這一個傳聞其實是有可能的
原因是因為你記憶體
你真的就是拿不到料 缺貨
可是所謂的TDP也就是熱功耗
要從2.3千瓦降到1.8千瓦
這件事情第一個我沒辦法驗證
第二個我也認為不太可能
那現在重點是Rubin Ultra
會不會從原本的說到三片
改回兩片式的均熱片
這個也是有可能的
之前不是在講兩片變一片嗎
兩片變一片嗎
那等一下我來講一下這個一片兩片三片
到底是什麼東西好了
但重點就是呢
你今天改回兩片有沒有可能
有可能 因為三片的良綠
你還沒有這麼的高
所以你先用兩片的
你可能到了下一代的Rubin Ultra
再慢慢的導入三片
也有機會
所以這個是有可能
那你要講說建設吊單
這個就完全不合理
因為不管是兩片式還是三片式
建設都是供應商都是他拿
上一次的故事
我們有跟大家分享
都還沒發生
他現在正在出貨中
就開始股價腰斬了
所以你看當時建設股價腰斬了股價後面又創新高事後回頭看這些利空都是讓我們去撿這種好公司便宜的好時機好 現在兩片式指的是什麼呢什麼呢這個是晶片 GPU
OK 好不好
然後你晶片
它不可能直接去跟金屬接觸
所以你中間一定要有所謂的導熱材
那我們講的一片兩片三片
指的是什麼
你GPU晶片上面有幾個金屬件
這個就是我們的定義
所以你會看到這裡
第一個散熱蓋是一個
水冷板是第二個
所以這叫兩片式
三片式是什麼呢
我中間有一個
加強的結構鍵
還有一個關鍵三件事
就是多了這個可拆上蓋
這是第二個金屬鍵
第三個是什麼 水冷板
所以這叫做三件事
OK 所以這個大家搞清楚了
好 那現在三件事厲害的地方在哪裡呢
我們剛剛講了重點在可拆上蓋
這個東西是什麼呢
我在封裝之前 出廠之前呢
我有這個機構鍵
我把它按在晶片上
因為晶片很脆弱
你如果不小心封裝去碰到
那片晶片就壞掉
所以如果你有一個東西可以去做保護
那這樣子很好
可是因為你任何的散熱
中間的東西越多 散熱的效率越差
所以它厲害的地方在哪
我今天封裝完
我上到這個所謂的機櫃裡面以後
我這一塊可以把它拆掉
我這一塊一拆掉以後呢
我的晶片基本上除了中間的導熱材
我直接跟水冷板貼在一起
散熱效率就很好
可是就是因為你要做這個
它的量率沒有這麼的高
因此我們看到的三片式跟兩片式
我們等於是順便幫大家介紹
那你說不管是兩片式還是三片式
說真的 建設都是供應商
所以我認為這個利空鬼故事
盤中一度殺到跌停
後面很多出來辟謠
說他是假消息或怎麼樣的
所以跌停板有打開
代表市場是可以接受
這個其實並不是真的大利空
好 而且有很多的股價
因為創歷史新高了
難免他有漲了很多的預期
一旦這個預期有點變化的可能性
他就下來了
其實現在市場
投資市場就是很容易這樣子
我們對啊 股價在高檔
那個眼裡是容不下一力殺的
那我們以股價型態
這根長黑黑
從技術面來講
很醜 非常的醜
因為它跌破了所有短中長期的均線
可是我們回到過去
我們有一台時光機
從這邊下來的
對 一度下來
從5000多塊下來的
下到這邊2800
那當時也是利空故事
你說這邊是要打對折
因為兩片變一片
這裡來打7折嗎
如果真的打7折
你真的要站滿房
我覺得不會啦
6 7 42
不太容易
這邊的話我們已經驗證過了
當你建設這邊的底部成型
它照理來講不應該要跌回這邊
跌回這邊反而真的不能滿
所以我會認為今天呢
一旦跌破了月線
它都是超跌啦
都是超跌
所以這邊的投信的籌碼還在
外資雖然小占賣方
可是我們相信的是公司的基本面
以及我們能夠知道的是
建設它不會掉單
因此這邊的股價跌的越多
反而都是減便宜的好機會
好 不過想明這一波投信厲害了
它其實這邊佈最多
就是底部起漲區
有沒有可能遇到投信的調節的話
閃門朋友們要稍微留意一下
這倒是有可能
因為我們相討時間來到了9月
底左右中旬過後
那會有所謂的投信的季底作帳
如果我們看到投信在這邊
開始有連續性的賣單
我是覺得可以先閃一下
等到季底作帳結束以後
我再把它買回來
也是一種策略
那當然啦 我們既然講到了散熱
這個散熱在接下來到年底之前
應該營收還是會越越高啦
在目前來講第一個
我們也看到了這個所謂的冷能專區
什麼是冷能
這個大家其實生活都會遇到
有沒有煮過那個小火鍋 瓦斯罐
你煮一煮那個瓦斯罐會變冰喔這他是不是會變冰的誰會去在燭火鍋的時候摸瓦斯罐因為我是負責換瓦斯的那個人所以大家會知道當今天液態的天然氣它要氣化
它就要吸周圍的熱
所以它會有很多的冷能
像冷氣一樣
這個時候中油有很多的液態天然氣
如果我把資料中心蓋在旁邊
我是不是就可以把這個冷能
直接拿來降溫
所以這是冷能專區
也就代表散熱重要
因為美國銀行就預測了
你在接下來
有將近七成的資料中心
全部都會用到液冷散熱的技術
因此我們台場的相關概念股
這個訂單長線來看
一定是沒有問題
我們今天幫大家挑了
8月營收年增超過20%
以及今年前8個月
累計營收超過25%的相關的概念股
那我們今天在這邊去做挑選的話
一樣整理了鎖定率
就是我們主力炫商
買超的集中度
目前來看高率其實還是蠻高的
那其他來講的話
雙龍也是高
其他像是這種大型的龍頭股
我們有講過
他的這個鎖定率通常不會太高
可是我們就可以去參考
然後另外還整理了預估的本益比
給大家參考
所以第一間我們來跟大家介紹
3324的雙紅
前面是真的達人秀很開心
因為我們常常覺得雙紅太委屈
憲榮也常常講
但後來漲了
那現在回檔到月線
是不是第二次的機會
絕佳機會
因為今天的最低點1240
你幹嘛那麼開心
我很喜歡股價跌
應該是跌了我們才有機會減便宜
今天低點1240
可是你看到月線是1236
所以代表月線這個位置是有支撐
再加上大戶的籌碼
不離不棄
變那麼多
而且這一波你看外資買上來
其實這一波修正下來
並不是外資殺的
也就代表外資的成本
還是在相對比較高檔的位置
因此股價回到月線
對我來講
我們都知道
營收在下半年來講的話
不會是太大的問題
所以這種股價
既然來到了關鍵的均線支撐
那對我來講
後面只要有任何一根長紅K
或許就是進場的機會
再來第二間公司
我們看2308的台達店
長得跟別人不一樣
這個要送暖一下
對啊
送暖送暖
以目前來講啦
這個地方的形態還是空投啦
這個我們也必須要這樣講
外資投信實在對他蠻狠的
這邊的包含他
投信他完全沒有要回頭買
那甚至外資在這邊
也都還是賣大於買
因此籌碼的角度來講的話
他依然不是一個
你可以放到口袋名單
可是我們講了龍頭的全殖股的大公司
你一定就是要趁著他股價大幅度修正
你才可以買的安心
你不能等他股價後面又漲上去
就像大力光像聯發科
一定是低檔買
你才會買的比較放心
買的比較舒服
所以台達電在這邊
預計要整理多久
我可以告訴大家
因為季線正在下彎
什麼時候會上彎
因為現在的季線的扣底值在這邊
我們可以看到以季線的扣底值
如果在這裡的話呢
它應該在後面還要整理將近一個月
它才會開始往上走
可是說真的
這種在低位階的股票
我們就是用時間來去換取空間
所以台達電的目前的本益比來講
對我我會認為其實算是合理
因此如果後面這裡
不要去破這個1425的話
在這個位置上面
你買起來放 買起來蹲
應該到年底之前
都會有不錯的報酬空間可以期待
以今年來說
可能本益比還沒有到很低
可是如果對於明年的成長性的話
明年本益比現在的股價是低的
對 現在的股價就是低的
20幾倍
所以我覺得是可以關注啦
那再來第二個部分
就是我們關於先進製程
先進封裝的部分
大家一直覺得說
為什麼封測股要動不動的
可是我給大家一個觀念
你隨著台積電
不管是在2奈米的製程
3奈米的製程
甚至下一代1.4nm的製程他們的頭片量越來越多你的封測的需求一定也會跟著上升特別是在CoreOS先進封裝今年年底13萬片這個已經是連續兩年幾乎是翻倍成長
你到了2028年底以後
這個數字還要再翻倍到26萬片
也就代表的是我們台灣相關的封測供應鏈
未來至少兩三年的訂單
你絕對就是你有產能他都會把它拿走
所以我會認為封測族群
近期的股價雖然沒有什麼表現
但那只是因為資金現在在觀望
因為資金現在在觀望
從基本面來講的話
他們都是非常強勁的
其實8月營收
他們已經開始陸陸續續
有展現成長性了
因為說實話
上半年風色成長性還好而已
是不是因為現在產能
還要等待擴出來之後
才有辦法進一步的跳增
沒錯 因為現在他們的營收數字
公布出來
這個數字不是他的天花板
是台積電COWAS產能的天花板
所以我們知道COWAS的產能
在今年第四季
大量的設備跟機台交際
會瞬間拉高
大家要期待這件事
所以我對於第四季
這一些相關的封測的營收數字
是非常有期待的
同樣的我們一樣去從這一些
去做營收年增去做篩選
而且以預估本益比
我們也幫大家算好了
這邊看起來估值
都其實都算蠻合理的
第一間我們就來看3711的日月光
這個日月光啊 高檔震盪
這個很折磨人
我挺擔心他過了一個月
還是這樣
我們就講了一整個月他這樣子
但獲利他的營收就是跳起來的
年增有到四五十%了
他的營收數字
就是不會讓大家失望的
那我會認為在均線附近這邊整理
你這邊整理夠久以後
他就是讓一些沒有耐心的籌碼被消化掉
而且你看這邊的外資
其實是一直站在買方的
所以既然他在這邊蹲
他就有點類似在吸籌碼
那我們講了
如果指數在這邊是要往上去創高的話
不就代表龍頭股
應該在後面也要跟著帶頭
在封測裡面
日月光既然能夠拿到台積電後段
這一個所謂COWAS的後面的WAS的部分
還有前段他在COW的部分
也要拿到外衣的訂單
因此我會認為以日月光投控
目前的本益比真的是有一點委屈
這個股價創高的話
只要後面台股我說了
我們往5萬點或4萬8千點去做挑戰
日月光在這裡整理完以後
只要一根長紅K
那個就是一根穿雲件
千鈞萬馬來相見
大家要把握
要把它放到口袋名單
觀察什麼時候去做突破表態
好
第二間公司我們來講6223的旺系
以整個探偵測試來講的話
今天第一個工上漲停的是雍智科技
雖然後面漲停有打開
可是我可以告訴大家
以探針測試這個基座
不管你做後面的FT FINAL TIME的測試
或者是你在探針卡的消耗上
數量今年一定會大幅度的增加
所以目前旺系來講在探針卡族群
我認為在龍頭
我們這個族群裡面
它一定是龍頭
那我現在觀察的
就是投信近期開始重新站回買方
外資這邊的動向還沒有那麼明確
可是投信一樣的
他願意在這個位置上面去做佈局
股價距離前低
說真的其實沒有很遠
所以法說會過後的股價修正
我們現在又回到了
法說會修正下來的那個相對低點
而我會認為在探針族群裡面
我喜歡龍頭的公司
因此在今年第二季
他就單季繳出了
EPS 15.55的數字
8月的營收年增率也將近七成
這種股價只要有修正到這邊
相對比較低位階的話
如果後面這幾天又有震盪
盤中又跌到了平盤下
對我來講
他就是在聯準會利率決策會議前
最好卡位的時機點
好 等於現在是一個找寶物的時間
對不對
噴出再買的話風險比較高
不妨現在來找一下
沒有錯
今天非常謝謝小明同學
謝謝小明